Speaker 1: This morning we woke up to what
was reported as a shocking number 33 percent,
33 percent approval for President Joe Biden,
a disastrously low number and the number is
true. But we're going to contextualize it.
It's just one poll. And while overall Joe
Biden's approval is not great, it's still
better than Trump's was at this point in time
in Trump's presidency. So without context,
the 33 percent number is not worth that much,
but it is not a good number. So let's start
with that 33 percent number. We have a new
Quinnipiac poll and indeed the poll finds,
and Quinnipiac is a good, good pollster that
only 33 percent of Americans approve of the
way that Joe Biden is handling his job. This
is a tie for the low ever received by Biden
in this poll. With January 12th, when it was
also 33 percent, now the main question for
me is why is it low and what could raise it
really the key to questions with any presidential
approval poll? But then we're also going to
compare it to other approval polls. So looking
at the Quinnipiac poll, we find that only
39 percent of Americans approve of Joe Biden's
handling of the response to the Russian invasion
of Ukraine 39 percent. That's a much lower
number than we saw weeks ago in other polls.
Now, part of it could be the way the poll
is done, and part of it likely is a decline
in approval of how Joe Biden has handled that
situation. Interestingly, more than eight
in 10 Americans believe Russian President
Vladimir Putin is a war criminal, something
that Donald Trump hesitates to say, and we
will get to that a little bit later. 10 percent
believe Putin is not a war criminal. Seven
in 10 think Putin ordered Russian troops to
kill civilians in Ukraine. 14 percent think
that he did not. So this is the Quinnipiac
poll. Well, what about more, generally speaking,
what's going on with Joe Biden's approval?
Well, for that, one of the best places to
look is the FiveThirtyEight Biden approval,
which looks at an average of recent approval
polls. And when we look there, we find that
it's not as bad for Joe Biden. Certainly,
it's not good. And as you can see early in
his presidency, Joe Biden in the mid-50s in
terms of approval, then moving into the low
50s crossing below the 50 percent line, getting
down into the mid-40s and then into the low
40s. And most recently, we see this little
decline from about forty two to forty one.
If you look more deeply at the specific polls
making that up, and this is where we would
say, OK, what is where does the Quinnipiac
poll fit into this? We see that the Quinnipiac
this recent Quinnipiac University poll is
here, which has Joe Biden at 33. That is an
outlier in the sense that all of the other
recent polls have Joe Biden between 38 and
44. Does that mean the Quinnipiac poll is
wrong? Well, no, it doesn't mean it's wrong,
but it does mean it is sort of an outlier.
And when FiveThirtyEight applies what they
call an adjustment, the three becomes 37.
So needless to say, this is not a good situation
for Joe Biden. And the question now is going
to be, well, what needs to happen for that
to change because these are not great numbers.
The next question would be are these guaranteed
to be destructive numbers, looking forward
at the midterms and potentially at 2024? Well,
one thing we can look at there. Is how does
the current Biden approval? Forty one point
something, how does that compare with other
presidents at this point in their presidencies?
If you look at Biden versus Trump, you find
that at this point in time, Trump actually
was at forty point six. I mean, it's more
or less the same. But Biden's approval today
is slightly better than was Trump's at this
point in his presidency. If you compare Biden
to basically any other recent president, you
see that Barack Obama had a higher approval.
At this point in time, George W. Bush had
a dramatically higher approval thanks to 911.
Bill Clinton had a higher approval than Biden.
George H.W. Bush had a much higher approval
than Biden. Reagan had a higher approval than
by, but you have to go all the way back to
Jimmy Carter to even get close. And even then,
just at this time, Carter also did better
than Biden. But soon Jimmy Carter started
seeing a reduction. What does this mean for
twenty twenty two? It's not good. It's not
good. There's really no way to spin it. That
feels empirically honest. And I know that
you're going to see hot takes from Democratic
pollsters and operatives and analysts that
are saying, Well, listen, the midterms are
not necessarily a referendum on Biden and
x y z. But if this doesn't change, it's going
to be a disaster for Democrats. There's just
no way around it. It is going to be potentially
one of the worst midterms for Democrats in
a very long time now. What could change it?
Many things could change it if the American
perception of the economy improves between
now and November. It's good for Democrats,
and I know many of you will say, but David,
the numbers are good for the economy. You're
absolutely right. But we did a story early
last week about the difference between an
economic reality and a political reality.
Jobs numbers are dramatically better now than
when Joe Biden took over, but a third of the
country doesn't think so. A third of the country
thinks jobs have been lost. I know we can
say, Oh, those stupid, if that's what they
believe, they're going to vote on that basis.
And so what matters is what people, what people
believe some kind of satisfactory resolution
in Ukraine, and it's hard to use that language.
Given the death and destruction that's been
seen there. Some kind of politically satisfactory
resolution will likely be helpful to Democrats
because I believe that the midterms are a
referendum on Joe Biden. I think there's no
way to argue that that they are not but not
good numbers for Joe Biden. And if nothing
changes, that's the key if nothing changes.
It will be a disastrous midterm for Democrats.
If you disagree with me. Let me know. Tell
me how the current numbers translate to an
OK midterm for Democrats. I just don't see
it